was es gibt und jetzt willkommen zu
einem land voller handicap games spiele
heute 64 jahre games aufgebahrt wir hier
schon sehen können und die heute ist
heute ihr handicap ist das folgende wir
wechseln uns nach jedem kill dazu dafür
dass ich maxis steuerung spiele und du
kriegst du für die kopfhörer
nein wer mich da auch nicht geändert
gehört fakt aber ich habe einfach immer
nimmt das wichtigste das man gemacht hat
eine 64er runde
das ist allerwichtigste immerhin werden
die steuern noch nicht geändert dann
höre meine ok alles klar
ich habe mir dann ich heute gedacht wir
spielen einfach mal abwechselnd umso
bisschen max hat noch seinen seinen
austauschschüler hier
ich hab ihm machen das zu dritt mit
francesco im kompletten minecraft aber
da lernen
das wäre wohl zu groß geworden okay okay
okay ich mache jetzt bei zweier teams
bestimmt gewesen
rechts richtung boden da wurde zulauf
ist
besonders krass oder vorne war ein
bissel schwer teilte jetzt wird mir leid
ich weiß einfach nicht immer gute sachen
bevor den muss ich erstmal lernen
jump'n'run verdienen und so werden hart
daran bissen von martin halter
auch wenn das keinen job mehr ankommt
wie sich jetzt erstmal irgendwie machen
jetzt vor allem deathmatch
das match ist eine sonderregelung oder
je nachdem wie viel noch da sind ja
stimmt wenn es halt viel sind und
sowieso irgendwo im hintergrund halten
müssen übereinander ist vielleicht doch
wieder ein verlierer-team leute wird man
sich letztens gesehen hatte von der
vierten stunde hier auf gomopa gespielt
und die war einfach ein scheiß sechster
team am spot geht durch das 96 team
asozial kann man sein zu sechs zu team
und die gehen auch alle sechs auf mich
drauf wechsel kein thema ich hab's dann
noch geschafft zwei von denen kaputt zu
machen weil er war ja für mich gut war
ich mal niemand der sein team macht hat
auch entfernt nur irgendeine ahnung von
dem spiel
also sorry aber da hab ich kein
verständnis für als den gegner gesehen
hat wo ist der forderung eingehen
heute ist ihr wagen die kiste war gut
das heißt ja irgendwo ist ein gegner
irgendwo nicht geblutet
hier wagen bekommt man die hoch die
kritik ist davon weil bedeutet darüber
schon einige einige fein verpackt wie
gehabt im spiel und du hast die dort
wird so auch gestern
da ist einer seiner es brauche ein
bisschen pid oder gut dies wichtig
nehmen wir mit der zeit wieder oben ist
aber auch einem kreis gehen vielleicht
mitarbeiter anders gesehen
auf dieser etappe mit ihm aber das ist
nicht meine sache zu wechseln einstein
schwester sprintet man das ist gut so
kannst du schnell ändern kannst einander
egal wer man jetzt die zeit glaube ich
wenn wir zusammen aufnehmen weil ich
übertreibe nicht
junge du bist langläufer das hätte ich
gekillt mit dem stehen geblieben wärst
du hast das volk vor deiner nase über
drei für eine show
du kannst dich bewegen werden und was
ihre plätze tauschen
du wolltest nicht will ihn bis auf 9
sorry so weit dass wir wieder unsere
mutter einfach keine ahnung was sie
gerade eine idee und leute sowieso
reingewinn immer auf die fängt an zu
reden
ok ich sagte ja weniger auf geh bitte
bleibt weiter anziehen
ziemlich ein baby
ich glaube genau diese schlichte jetzt
noch erhoffte vorgehen aller routine mit
ihm über mittel soll ich denn machen ja
und was läuft gut packen boden genau was
wir brauchen ist das braucht leute
schaut man die kommentare von halte dass
der hier das tnt so verschwendet ich
finde finde ich ziemlich
unverantwortlich wir haben betrag der
begrenzten ressourcen dieser erde da
einfach so ein tnt wegzuhauen gut
anderer seite damit vernichtet ich will
doch nur für raps ist es gefangen
die hier lang spazieren
ich sage ich eine gute idee leute was
haltet ihr davon wenn man einfach den
gesamten abfall der welt von minecraft
mäßig explodieren lässt dann wer ist weg
oder ich glaube die ganze welt
funktioniert minecraft regeln ok dann
ein register also letztens hat man ja
wieder an so einer fliegenden sandburg
vorbeigelaufen bericht will ich es
einfach so ich melde mich damit
ausgezahlt beim entsprechend kommt
kriegt den nobelpreis für und vom
preisgeld kopf in der neuen pc heißt
dann habe ich jeden tag live streams und
studie auch nicht macht mich dann auf
einmal
austria bin der boss habe ich nicht
studieren alles nur durch minecraft
abermals nachkam schönheit selbst hat
sich der held trinkgefäß hab ich ja auf
welcher endlich kann sie dort den weg
geworfen oder du vielleicht nehme ich
viel also leute ihr könnt danach aber
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher ist das
nicht gemacht hat
jan eismann kann ihnen so gar nicht
sehen
direkt ich dachte ich sogar ich sehe
daher gehen fast und kompost und das ist
richtig kritisch all das hier würde da
bist wenn eine rakete direkt davor
stellt oder 36 feierabend ja sehr gut
ich bin 100 - auch wenn eigentlich leute
wenn vielen leuten drin stecken und die
dann sterben droppen die dann die feier
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
also die leute kann es wieder mal in die
kommentare schreiben
ihr wisst schon weisheit der vielen und
somit auch die segmente zu alten preisen
hämmern maxis oder ich eine steuer aber
nicht unter wasser nicht vermieteter
wasser nicht unter was leute ein ganz
schlauer
sonst laufen wir nachher noch ab dabei
das war mir auch nicht sagen ich finde
das macht richtig spaß bisher vor allem
weil man es auch wirklich nicht schlecht
schreiben dafür dass jedes mal ab
wechseln müssen du bist schon castaño
aber vielleicht ist dann wieder aus und
spricht so aber bei mir schon mal ganz
anders
ich sehe den kuchen die hat man riskiert
kann denn deine richtung st ich sitze ja
auch gerade ein bisschen seitlich leute
deswegen kommen 40 bisschen komisch kann
ich meinen beide haben hier drunter
packung soja funktioniert alles klar ist
der beste tipp wenn man machen kann auch
im doppel auf dem server wenn irgendwie
verfolgt bis von einem team
mehrfach durch ein 2 1 gegen die dänen
zum beispiel platziert da kann ich da
oben raus heute nicht rein dass wir
nicht sehr gefragt hier kannst du auch
selbst öffnung öffnet auch die rezession
oder durch dabei hatte hat aber nichts
kann man das in blockieren kann man
nicht nein es nicht leute wie mich steht
jedes mal wieder richtig ob adhs kurz
darauf dass der mensch gehört mir
dennoch sehe ich gar nicht ein gehört
laut echt richtig gut man es aber durch
direkt island lang ihre kinder im park
in europa nur noch drei leute
das heißt dass maximal noch ein
zweierteam jugend wir können die runde
einfach first rail gewinnen
ja ok in der kehle du hast du verdient
junge leute ab es noch was ist nun mal
ein statement wir haben es geschafft was
auf steuerung also dieses umgestellt wo
ich jetzt nicht mal ein spiel mit meiner
er ich bin mit einer aufwarten die
kleine web die kleinen
getroffen
hey was machen die zuschauer denn dass
die pfeile die ganze etwas lebten
abwechselnd scheiße einer du bist ja das
alter [ __ ] nein mein alter ich war live
scheiße und die steuerung hat mir nicht
getaugt man achtfache legal leute die
runde war auf jeden fall richtig geile
auch wenn es am ende leider nicht
geschafft haben ihr könnt natürlich
leichter lassen
würdest du sehr feiern einfach daumen
runter und die könnte die
kommentarschreiber handicap er als
nächstes sehen wollte wie immer
natürlich immer die kommentare und sehe
was ihr da so schreibt wenn es gut ist
mache ich es auch
und ansonsten will ich sage ich heute
gefangen hat das gut für sie